hello everyone so as you might have
heard russia has invaded ukraine full
scale all directions with the full use
of their arsenal this video is an
analysis of the current situation in
ukraine taking into account multiple
aspects of the war at the time of making
this video it's the 12th day of the
invasion and russians while having
caused massive damage and casualties
have not managed to achieve any of their
main military objectives in fact they're
taking very heavy losses during all this
to the point where some say ukraine
might just be able to win against the
second most powerful military on the
planet so okay what the hell is
happening here to understand we'll go
through what russians originally planned
and what ended up happening instead but
before that as a quick public service
announcement if you're a ukrainian
journalist my sponsor atlas is giving
you a free one-year vpn subscription for
instructions follow the link in the
description meanwhile the rest of us get
a special discount meaning 82 of your
three-year plan for 199 per month plus
one month three with a 30-day money-back
guarantee they offer a high-speed
service suitable both for streaming and
gaming moreover with a single
subscription you'll be able to protect
all your devices at the same time and
not only that atlas also comes with an
ad blocker and malware protection it
blocks all the malicious links ads and
trackers and notifies you when someone
is trying to steal your data it also
helps you get the best deals while
shopping online this includes online
subscription services such as netflix or
spotify also airlines hotels and more
right now atlas vpn is running a huge
discount it means you can get a 3 year
subscription for just 199 a month with a
30 day money back guarantee time is
running out so grab the deal by clicking
the link in the description below with
your subscription you will also have
access to atlas's data breach monitor
feature and here's how that works inside
the app you go to bridge scanner you
type in your email and the app will let
you know whether your personal
information had been leaked through a
passed or recent breach so make sure to
take advantage of atlas vpn's huge
discount that's a three year
subscription for just 199 per month with
a 30 day money back guarantee link in
the description thank you for checking
out atlas vpn heads like this helps
support what i do and now back to the
program
so the russians plan to see ukraine was
essentially a blitzkrieg based on
documents found in destroyed columns
they wanted to get this [ __ ] done within
two weeks i.e achieve all their
objectives plus ukraine's capitulation
sharpie viewers might notice that as of
now the 12th day russians aren't even
close to achieving any objectives turns
out russia severely miscalculated
expecting low ukrainian resistance and a
quick advance the plan was the following
break out of crimea and move west and
east land a bunch of troops around
odessa link up with the west moving
troops and then circle the city the east
heading troops were to continue to mario
pool where they link up with the forces
from the dunbas encircling mariopol
itself harkiv was to be encircled as
well with forces coming from the east
and northeast in the north russians were
to take cities like sumi and cherniv
then proceed down towards kiev join
troops from the northeast and once again
encircle the city so in the russian
dream scenario within two or three days
most major ukrainian cities are
encircled meanwhile their armies are
rolling through the countryside forcing
a quick and desperate surrender in kiev
and ukraine is annexed before the west
can recover from its confusion they even
pre-wrote an article for this occasion
which people found on the rio novosti
website titled russia's offensive and
the new world it's google translated to
english russia is restoring its unity
the tragedy of 1991 this terrible
catastrophe in our history its unnatural
dislocation has been overcome yes at a
great cost yes through the tragic event
of a virtual civil war because now
brothers separated by belonging to the
russian and ukrainian armies are still
shooting at each other but there will be
no more ukraine as anti-russia russia is
restoring its historical fullness
gathering the russian world the russian
people together in its entirety of great
russians belorussians and the little
russians if we had abandoned this if we
had allowed the temporary division to
take hold for centuries that we would
not only betray the memory of our
ancestors but also be cursed by our
descendants for allowing the
disintegration of the russian land
vladimir putin has assumed without a
drop of exaggeration a historic
responsibility by deciding not to leave
the solution of the ukrainian question
for future generations after all the
need to solve it would always remain the
main problem for russia for two key
reasons and the issue of national
security that is the creation of
anti-russia from ukraine as an outpost
for the west to put pressure on us is
only the second most important among
them now this problem is gone ukraine
has returned to russia this does not
mean that its statehood will be
liquidated but it will be reorganized
re-established and returned to its
natural state as part of the russian
world in what borders in what form will
the alliance with russia be fixed
through the csto and the eurasian union
or the union state of russia and belarus
this will be decided after the end is
put in the history of ukraine as
anti-russia in any case the period of
the split of the russian people is
coming to an end this is literal nazi
[ __ ] by the way territorial conquest
based on ethno-nationalism aiming to
restore the mythical past greatness of
russia oh by the way the russian
invasion is officially called special
military operation to denuzify ukraine
go figure however as i've mentioned
before the russian blitzkrieg didn't
work it's day 12 no major objectives
have been achieved and russians are
taking heavy losses everywhere to
understand where they [ __ ] up let's go
back to the very beginning the whole
invasion began by russians unloading on
ukraine with ballistic missiles hitting
military bases airports and so on this
was done to [ __ ] ukrainian defenses
of course break their chain of command
and send them into chaos so russians can
just roll in and mop them up however
ukrainians got intel from nato just in
time and managed to shuffle things
around right before the strikes while
some things did get destroyed most
equipment survived and very importantly
the chain of command remained intact the
predicted chaos among the defenders also
didn't happen ukrainians stood their
ground as a result russians started
[ __ ] up right at their first
objective namely harkiv that was the
first location where they got bogged
down and they haven't managed to advance
ever since in the south russians did
achieve at least some success having
managed to advance to mario paul in the
east and successfully encircling it so
now comes the hard part for those troops
i.e to actually try and take the city
and that will take weeks at best with
heavy losses and block by block urban
warfare in the north russians did manage
to roll into cities like sumi but were
promptly beaten out and forced back to
the outskirts as of now the most
important cities in the north are under
ukrainian control russians were supposed
to take these cities on their way to
kiev but when they couldn't they simply
went around them instead focusing all
their efforts on kiev but this is
leading to additional losses since they
had to stretch their supply lines
further in hostile areas but the real
fuck-ups have been happening around kiev
an important strategic objective to the
north west is hostomal airport which the
russians initially took with a massive
helicopter raid some two dozen
helicopters rolled through clearing out
the defenses followed by elite russian
paratroopers but then they were defeated
by ukrainians who took back the airport
and not only that but ukrainians also
shut down two il-76 transport planes
that's easily 300 plus kia russian elite
soldiers this was a huge loss of face
for the russian military russians then
broke in from the north proper taking
the chernobyl zone in the process but
they once again got bogged down this
time in kiev's northern suburbs where
ukrainians blew up bridges and keep
harassing their columns suburbs like
earpin and bucha are consequently full
of wrecked russian hardware aside from
the ukrainian army and the territorial
defenses ukrainian spec ops are also
operating in the area hence the lack of
russian progress okay so why do russians
move in easy to ambush columns instead
of simply rolling through the land the
answer is the mild weather turning
fields into swamps and them getting
stuck in mud is only one of the reasons
why they avoid it the second reason is
the lack of tire maintenance turns out
wheeled vehicles need to be moved at
least once a month otherwise their tires
decay and become brittle if you decrease
pressure at that point the tire will
simply tear itself apart and turns out
tires need to be depressurized so the
vehicles don't sink in the mud so yeah
for russians driving across the fields
either means getting stuck in the mud or
having tyrus strand for this reason they
have to keep to the roads which makes
them easier targets for defenders other
problems for the russians include morale
and logistics russian troops are
fighting against a quote-unquote
fraternal people for no good reason
other than putin's imperial ambitions
however many of their troops are
essentially kids in their early 20s
conscripts who were forced to sign
papers making them temporary contractors
so they can be deployed into a war zone
meanwhile ukrainian morale is very high
despite everything but where the
russians truly [ __ ] up is their
logistics they don't have enough food
and fuel thus russians just leave
vehicles with empty tanks on the
roadside only to be blown up or towed
away by ukrainians there are cases of
russian soldiers looting grocery stores
for food and knocking on locals doors at
night asking to buy food and fuel for
any price the russian army simply didn't
have enough trucks and other logistics
systems for this invasion and what they
have is decreasing rather fast just
their visually confirmed truck losses
are currently above 200. this maelstrom
of incompetence has resulted in images
like this four russian tunguska sams
consisting 16 million dollars each
abandoned next to the road and then
locals setting them on fire i believe
however that in the following days the
focus of attention will shift towards
the south here the russians are far more
successful since they are operating out
of established military bases in crimea
among other things there's a great
threat on twitter about this by retired
major general mik ryan which i recommend
you check out basically mario paul will
likely fall in the future and if odessa
is taken that will be a huge long-term
issue for the ukrainians so we should
look at how the situation will develop
in the coming days there but the
military conflict is only one of the
aspects of the invasion there's also an
information war going on which ukraine
is winning consequently aside from the
terminally online weirdos and open
fascists pretty much everyone in the
developed world is pro-ukrainian right
now the russian narrative didn't stick
overwhelmed by well reality and savvy
use of mass media by the ukrainian
leadership on the economic front russia
is heading towards a collapse oh i mean
special economic descent in my bad the
us dollar currently costs around 120
rubles up from around 75 a few weeks ago
russia has been severely limited or
outright cut off from pretty much every
global financial system we'll see how
the invasion will develop in light of
all this since you know russia actually
has to pay for it in the meantime
russians have switched to indiscriminate
bombing of ukrainian cities and civilian
infrastructure which is a war crime by
the way but also a sign of their
frustration their victory is still far
away though rolling through the
countryside is the easy part taking
cities block by block is the hard part
and then maintaining their occupation is
the expensive part so we'll see how the
situation will develop and we might see
some limited russian success in the
future followed by a peace agreement or
maybe putin will just press the button
very unlikely but possible as i
mentioned the south will be key here so
you should keep an eye on that for now
in the meantime thank you for watching
and don't forget to like and subscribe
and i'll be seeing you next time with
more updates on the ukrainian invasion
you